Chổn, thôi, mũ mò, hay là mình là ăn, là mùn em lướng, một gói đầy đùa của tích kia.
Chỉ bá mi chỉ nhìn, đã bao gồm đạo phía sịt, bường gòn, bởi tích kịp chi phí, bởi tích kẹp thời gian.
Và cận đợi phải đau đâu.
Bây giờ, xin dây nắm, nguyễn rồi phải làm khoa lất cóc như một cái dí thực tập nên lại khá là bắt,
thường em sẽ ăn một bình hô, nhưng mà ăn một mình chỉ cũng, khá là tất tịp nữ lụng lụng lại,
phó khó khó khó ra để nổn nướng.
Hãy là đi một mình cũng nại, đặt đồ ăn thì chắc như những chi phí khác của vụng có lần em đặt nữ bắt sợ.
Chỉ có đặt năng như nổn nguyễn mà mong hồn, kênh cả chi chỉ đọng hộp chi phí đất chứng lụng,
bởi tên đôi nơi lên tối tất một trong niềm.
Nhưng mà tự kiện nhất mấy mộ sút tập nơi ăn của rác phút khi mọc khu đả,
tệ lợng hơn rất là nhiều, mỗi sắp chỉ có bao nhiêu chi lình hồ đã có gồm đất cạnh,
những tại chi phí khác, bởi tịp kẹp thời gian nữa.
Có tính chết công việc vào sống mục mình đến việc ăn hủ tụng mình rất là phá loa,
vì tụi đặt đồ ăn ngoài.
Một khiều bắt tệ với mình nè là khóan ăn đây là người ta hả cho có bố và khóan ăn lối,
nó rất ăn đồ mình.
Còn khi mọc là gì mình sẽ đặt tụi,
2 đến 3 sữa ăn cho cả ngày.
Như vậy, chỉ mấy thằng sốc thì mối,
khoai lại ở quan đấy mình trong quan ăn,
tự lúc đánh, lúc đánh, lúc sút tập một mấy ăn của gói ra phút khi việc ăn chứng không mình.
Sút tự nhiệt.